[Musica]
quanti di voi hanno un cellulare
quanti di voi hanno una bici
quanti di voi hanno un sex toy
dal 2015 mi occupo di design
questo tipo di design
il design di un servizio che migliora la
vita delle persone
possiamo definire il design come un
insieme di praticità tecnologia ed
estetica che avvicinano un oggetto
all'esigenza del pubblico e ne
migliorano la vita
ho passato gli ultimi sette anni a
vendere sex toy
e a fare divulgazione sulle tematiche
sessuali
ascoltando storie e raccogliendo
feedback ho capito che lo strumento sex
toy ha il potere di portare un
cambiamento positivo nelle persone
migliorandone appunto la vita
una vita migliore per tutti è progresso
un sex toy come un cellulare migliora la
vita delle persone ed è quindi progresso
ma allora perché la maggior parte delle
persone che ci sono qua oggi non ha
alzato la mano
vediamo due possibili ragioni la prima
bassa considerazione dello strumento per
mancanza di informazioni sulla salute
sessuale
un sex toy migliora la vita delle
persone
ma nessuno ce lo dice
non vediamo in giro pubblicità con
l'ultimo toy appena uscito con le sue
funzionalità pazzesche
mio padre mi accompagnò ad acquistare il
mio primo cellulare ma non mi accompagnò
acquistare il mio primo dildo mio nonno
mi insegnò ad usare la bici ma non mi
insegnò ad usare il mio primo vibratore
sarebbe stato un po troppo imbarazzante
e poi non era neanche il suo ruolo
ma allora di chi è la responsabilità
ci si deve occupare di un aspetto così
importante
per la nostra salute
nella mia unica lezione di educazione
sessuale al liceo durata un ora
ho imparato a mettere un preservativo su
una banana
mi sono mancate le informazioni di base
su come fare le cose e mi sa che qua ci
ritroviamo un po tutti
anzi forse proprio tutti
come lo dimostra una delle ultime
ricerche di pornhub che evidenzia che
una delle parole più cercate del 2021 è
stata proprio how to come fare
con il 245 per cento di ricerche in più
rispetto all'anno precedente entrando
quindi nella top ten delle parole più
cercate
how to put on and on how to squirt auto
finger myself how to save my bones come
tra darmi le palle
chiediamo proprio tutto ai nostri motori
di ricerca tanto che pornhub è diventato
il punto di riferimento per l'educazione
fai da te ed il motivo è solo uno
pornhub non ti giudica
e veniamo quindi qui al secondo motivo
per il quale molte persone non hanno
alzato la mano
la paura del giudizio degli altri
il giudizio non è un'idea legata a te
ma all'immagine che tu hai di te
a questa immagine attribuiamo la nostra
amabilità
vale a dire quanto siamo bravi o amabili
agli occhi degli altri
il giudizio ci può servire per guidarci
nella infinita
quantità di informazioni e input che
riceviamo tutti i giorni
se però l'indicatore della nostra
amabilità tende verso il negativo
siamo pronti a mettere in discussione i
nostri desideri i nostri credo in favore
di amici parenti o follower per essere
appunto più amabile
ma può uno strumento utile a
semplificare la nostra vita
complicare quella degli altri
spesso non ci rendiamo conto che il
giudizio esplicito e diretto verso gli
altri verso le persone non tiene conto
del loro contesto
è uno strumento potenzialmente utile si
trasforma in una trappola
perché fa leva su un sentimento molto
comune
la vergogna
provare vergogna e naturale prima
vergogna se ci sentiamo diversi ho
attaccato in quanto diversi
può venire quindi da dentro o da fuori
voglio aprire un sexy shop
penso a mia madre non mi guarderà più in
faccia mio figlio non avrà più il
coraggio di farsi vedere in giro con me
i miei amici mi prenderanno in giro
limitiamo quindi la nostra vita per
piacere agli altri per essere accettati
dagli altri
ma gli altri faranno così con altri e
questi altri con altri ancora
andando ad attivare un effetto domino
negativo che porta all'involuzione e non
all'evoluzione
l'evoluzione umana è fatta anche di
piccoli step
piccole azioni quotidiane che vanno
contro il credo la tradizione del tempo
nel quale vengono proposti
come per esempio un padre che decide di
mettersi lo smalto sulle unghie per
supportare il figlio bulli dato pagni
macisti perché si era messo lo smalto
sulle unghie
lourdes maria ciccone che si presenta
agli ultimi match cala con un glorioso
pelo sotto l'ascella e una pancia
traballante
elliot page che decide di fare il suo
percorso di trasformazione per diventare
finalmente la persona che voleva essere
il giudizio blocca gli altri dalle
infinite possibilità che a noi non
piacciono
se a me non piace tu non lo devi fare tu
me lo devi fare
se a me non piace tu non lo devi fare
che fare quindi
ognuno di noi può essere a suo modo
rivoluzionario
rivoluzionario ti supporta personalmente
nel tuo percorso di trasformazione
capendo quali sono le tue potenzialità
rispettando t e mettendo in discussione
le proprie convinzioni limitanti
l'evoluzione ario ci supporta ad
iniziare il tuo percorso
secondo i tuoi tempi e le tue modalità
l'evoluzione ario opera al contrario del
rivoluzionario che porta un cambiamento
veloce e con la forza che è spesso
pensato per esistere e non per resistere
ho passato diverse settimane a cercare
di capire come avrei potuto condividere
delle idee con così tante persone
diversamente vulnerabili e ho capito che
per fare l'evoluzione non servono eroine
o eroi
abbassa al dialogo 1 a 1
tu
fratello sorella
professoressa maestro
ricerca informati cerca fonti
attendibili sulla sessualità
parla senza vergogna parlane con i tuoi
amici ma anche quelle persone che non
conosci parla in modo semplice di sesso
impegnati a non giudicare ma a conoscere
l'approccio evoluzionario alla
comunicazione è contagioso perché è
liberatorio chi comunica conta già
positivamente l'altra persona che si
sente supportata
rispettata e stimolata e questa persona
farà così con un'altra persona
e quest altra persona con un'altra
persona
andando ad attivare quindi un effetto
domino positivo che è un potere enorme
in mano ad ognuno di noi in grado di
cambiare le future generazioni
quindi
tu continua a capire che cosa ti fa
stare bene
fa il primo passo verso il dialogo e si
il cambiamento grazie
[Musica]